[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
en un hecho sin precedentes el gobierno
de colombia anunció la creación de un
estatuto temporal de protección para los
migrantes venezolanos en el país se
trata de una decisión que busca
disminuir las cifras de la migración
irregular proteger al migrante mediante
la regularización e integrarlos a la
vida productiva garantizando todos sus
derechos la medida tendrá una vigencia
de 10 años tiempo tras el cual los
beneficiados podrán tramitar una visa de
residentes si es que deciden quedarse en
el país colombia es el principal
receptor de los venezolanos en la región
migración colombia estima que a
diciembre de 2020 más de un millón 729
mil venezolanos se encontraban en el
país y las cifras podrían seguir
aumentando ante la crisis en el país
vecino veamos a continuación en qué
consiste el estatuto de protección
anunciado por el gobierno colombiano
una decisión histórica en materia de
migración colombia regularizará
temporalmente a los migrantes
venezolanos nosotros hacemos pública la
decisión de nuestro país
de crear un estatuto de protección
temporal en colombia
que nos permita hacer un proceso de
regularización
de esos migrantes que están en nuestro
país la medida acoge a quienes ya se
encuentran en el país de manera
irregular que actualmente son más de
960.000 los que ya están regularizados
no tendrán que acudir a estar haciendo
actualizaciones constantes de sus
permisos sino que tendrán un proceso de
mayor estabilidad
y a quienes están en nuestro país en
condición de irregulares tendrán una
hoja de ruta a esa regularización pero
con el fin de desincentivar la migración
ilegal quienes entren al país durante
los próximos dos años podrán acogerse a
la vigencia de este estatuto será de
hasta diez años y transcurrido este
tiempo los interesados en seguir en
colombia podrán optar a ser residentes
cifras de acnur señalan que en la
actualidad 5,4 millones de venezolanos
viven fuera de su país de esa cantidad
más de 17 millones viven en colombia
muchos de ellos bajo unas difíciles
condiciones humanitarias que el anuncio
de colombia de otorgar protección
temporal a los venezolanos que se
encuentran en su territorio por un
periodo de 10 años es un gesto
humanitario emblemático para la región
con usted existe inclusive para el mundo
íntegro según migración colombia a pesar
de la pandemia y el cierre de fronteras
se estima que diariamente más de 300
migrantes intentan ingresar de manera
irregular al país
en la práctica con el estatuto de
protección temporal los migrantes
venezolanos podrán trabajar formalmente
abrir cuentas bancarias y acceder a
servicios básicos como salud y educación
entre otros pero no significa que les
abra la puerta para que ejerzan el voto
en colombia un tema que ha generado
polémica en el país los venezolanos
esperan que el anuncio cambie sus
condiciones de vida así reaccionaron a
la medida si nos va a ayudar un poco más
por lo menos en nuestro caso que estamos
emprendiendo que estamos aquí queriendo
tener un negocio legal como debe ser
esto nos va a permitir poder espero yo
acceder a un microcrédito podrás tener
una vida crediticia y de verdad uno por
lo menos de mi parte yo vengo a trabajar
y si se me da la oportunidad de tener
de mucha ayuda de francia adiós y hasta
el presidente pg
como
no estaba en la calle
pero cuál es el paso a seguir para los
venezolanos que se acogerán el estatuto
de protección temporal se lo preguntamos
a juan francisco espinoza director de
migración colombia el estatuto temporal
de protección es una ventana de
oportunidad quiere decir que no opera de
manera automática cada migrante que
quiera ser parte de esta gran
oportunidad deberá en primer término
hacer una operación del prerregistro
todo por página web por aplicaciones
tecnología una caracterización
socioeconómica que nos permita conocerlo
a profundidad para orientar política
social para apoyarlos para generar
mayores oportunidades y de ahí pasarán a
una segunda fase que es de
identificación biométrica captura de
huellas digitales iris todos los rasgos
personales para el final de este proceso
obtener su identificación este es un
mecanismo seguro para el migrante y para
colombia'
con esta medida colombia reconoce el
aporte de los migrantes en el desarrollo
de la economía del país y la importancia
de los venezolanos dentro del mercado
laboral la decisión contrasta con lo que
pasa en chile donde el gobierno ordenó
la deportación de al menos un centenar
de venezolanos que ingresaron
irregularmente por la región de coltán
en un pequeño pueblo en la frontera con
bolivia desbordado por la llegada de los
migrantes en su mayoría venezolanos
hasta que inmigrantes de france24
seguiremos cubriendo la actualidad de la
migración en américa latina y en el
mundo en todas sus facetas los invitamos
a comentar en nuestras redes sociales
con el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan
conectados con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]